now let's talk specifically about
organizational libraries organizational
libraries are libraries just like jQuery
but instead of focusing on Ajax and Dom
manipulation they focus on application
organization MVC or mvvm what we know is
Model View octopus and often some other
things as well now there are a lot of
organizational libraries out there but
they're all solving the same problem in
fundamentally similar ways they do have
slight differences in organization or
implementation and that's what the
documentation is for but by now if you
understand the basics of separation of
concerns then you can understand any of
these organizational libraries now what
about frameworks what is a framework and
how do they differ from organizational
libraries
well while scripting this course I
talked to a bunch of people about this
question because I was a little fuzzy on
it myself
and it turns out everyone has a
different answer and none of them fit
100% with what libraries and frameworks
call themselves so let's take a step
back here's the real issue it's not one
person or institution defining these
words it's a community of thousands and
thousands of developers and they aren't
all on the same page as each other
some people say frameworks are
collections of libraries some other
people say that frameworks call view
render methods while the libraries
require you to call them there's a wide
range of definitions and if you do want
proof of this do a quick google search
and start counting in fact if you look
at the edit history for the wikipedia
pages on javascript for libraries and
frameworks you'll even see disagreement
among the editors themselves so what is
the difference between an organizational
library and a framework well it feels
like a cop-out but I would say don't
worry about it too much
organizational libraries and frameworks
both solve the same problem and in
similar ways so to me at least it
doesn't matter a ton what we call it it
just matters that we can use them
regardless of what they call themselves